[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEX BUTNAREANU: Hey,
you look stressed.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I'm trying to
migrate to the cloud,
but I also have to come up
with this encryption strategy?
Like, I don't have
time for this.
I've already got my hands full.
ALEX BUTNAREANU: OK, well,
I have some good news.
With Google, moving to
the cloud will actually
give you encryption by default.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Encryption by default?
Can you show me how that works?
ALEX BUTNAREANU: Sure thing.
Let's take a look.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEX BUTNAREANU:
Encryption at rest
is central to our
security strategy,
and there are several options
based on the customer's
security needs.
By default, data at rest is
encrypted in all Google Cloud
Platform products.
For certain classes of data or
where you have a requirement
to manage your
encryption key, we
give customers the option
of managing their own keys
using Customer-Managed
Encryption Keys, or CMEC
for short, using a managed
service called Cloud KMS.
Then, for a small
percentage of workloads,
there may be a requirement to
generate your own encryption
key or manage it on premise.
And for that we
provide the option
to use Customer-Supplied
Encryption Keys, or CSEC
for short.
Let's see how this works.
By default, when I upload
a file to cloud storage,
it will automatically
be encrypted at rest
with Google-managed
keys, as we can see here.
This is transparent
to the user, but a lot
happens behind the scenes.
Data's split into
chunks, and each chunk
is encrypted with a unique
data encryption key.
Then these data
encryption keys are
encrypted with their
own key encryption keys,
stored in Google's KMS.
The data chunks are then
distributed across Google Cloud
Storage systems and replicated
in encrypted form for backup
and disaster recovery.
And this happens in real
time, all by default
and transparent to the user.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, that's a relief.
But, like, I still have
to manage our key rotation
policies.
And I've got keys that I have
to do hardware-backed encryption
for.
What am I supposed
to do about that?
ALEX BUTNAREANU: No worries.
We can handle that too.
Let me show you how.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Sure.
ALEX BUTNAREANU: Cloud KMS is
a hosted Key Management Service
that lets you manage
crypto keys for you
cloud services similar to the
way you'd do it on premise.
It's also integrated into cloud
IM and cloud auto-logging,
so you can manage permissions
and individual keys
and monitor how they are used.
We'll start by
creating a new keyring.
First, we name it.
Then, we can choose a
location like make global.
However, the rank
location matters based
on where my resources are.
I'm going to pick US central, as
that's where my workloads are.
Now I create my key.
First, I can specify the name.
Then, each key has
a purpose which
defines the cryptographic
capabilities of the key.
I'm going to choose to use
this to do symmetric encrypt
or decrypt.
I can then choose if this is
software- or hardware-backed.
If there is a requirement to
use hardware, we can use HSM.
Cloud HSM is a Cloud Hosted
Hardware security module
service that allows you
to host encryption keys
and perform
cryptographic operations
in a cluster of Phipps 140-2
level 3 certified HSMs,
all managed by Google for you.
Next, I can specify
the rotation period,
which is the time between
when the new key versions are
generated automatically.
And let's say I want
to go ahead and use
hardware encryption via HSM,
and make the rotation period 30
days, and click "create."
Let's go back to our
storage bucket example
I can create a new
bucket and configure
it to use my new
customer-managed encryption
key policies.
I give it a name.
Region is still US central
with my keys and HSMs,
and now I can change
the encryption options
from Google-managed key
to customee-managed key.
Soon as I do that, my
keyring and keys pop up,
and I can choose
which one to use.
Lastly, I need to
authorize a service account
to perform, encrypt,
and decrypt operations
with the key I just selected.
Granted.
Now when I upload a
file, whether it's
a few kilobytes or
a few petabytes,
it will be encrypted
using my key.
So let's upload a file called
"Super Important File."
And you can see it's indeed
using customer-managed keys,
and it's the actual
key I selected.
When I click on
it, I can open it.
Now let's go back to my keys.
The whole point
of CMEC using KMS
is to give customers
control over key policies.
So let's say I want to go
and now disable that key.
Once I disable it,
although not immediately,
I will no longer be
able to access the file.
Let's try it.
Software key's been disabled.
I try to open the file.
I can see that I can no longer
access it, and the error I get
is that cloud KMS has been
disabled or destroyed.
And in the KMS UI, I can
see that the key I was using
was indeed disabled.
That's what we mean by
customer-managed keys.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Wow,
so now I have the option
to choose what encryption
strategy makes sense for me,
and I can mix and match for
different parts of my cloud
migration.
ALEX BUTNAREANU: That's right.
Encryption is a
complex topic, so we
work really hard to make
sure the full complexity is
abstracted away.
That way, you get
the best innovations
and control where you need it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Don't
forget to like, comment,
and subscribe for more great
Google Cloud Platform content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]